folks Joe D Roa here I am out on the
road doing those live shows all over the
place and uh let's folks Jo de R Roa
here I am out doing live shows all over
the place by myself not with the Pod
just alone solo doing my thing uh first
up November 9th New York New York I'm
doing a special show this is a selected
readings I'm going to be reading entries
for my audio book The Penthouse papers
so plus plus some other stuff I've had
published over the years uh that's for
the New York com Festival in New York
New York at the KGB bar on November 9th
November 11th Philadelphia PA theater of
the Living Arts almost sold out only a
few tickets left please come out to that
November 17th we're sold out Pittsburgh
PA at the bottle rocket November 18th
Buffalo New York theater at senica 1
again almost sold out buy your tickets
Please November 30th Denver Colorado at
the summit December 1st Phoenix Arizona
at the Crescent Ballroom December 3rd
Salt Lake City in Utah at the soundwell
and January 13th just announced New York
New York gramar SE theater folks new
hour popping off at the grammar seat and
all of those other venues I just listed
with the exception of the KGB bar show
that's the only one that's not me doing
I never Promise You a Rose Garden I'm
going to be doing readings from the book
at that show and that show only Anyway
come check me out joder rosa.com for all
the show info and your ticket links and
as usual if you're in New York please
please please come see us at Joey roses
open 7 days a week at 11:30 a.m. every
day delicious sandwiches cheap drinks
come see us and if you want info about
the venue Joey roses nc.com what's up
guys real quick tour dates are on sale
right now at salvano comedy.com there's
a big Illinois run in November leading
up to my comedy special at the Vic in
Chicago on December 1st and 2nd the
second sold out as you guys I hopefully
know uh and so we edit two shows on the
first all will be taped and all all if
you have a ticket to any of those shows
you'll be eligible to win uh a flight
hotel and trip to the set of Impractical
Jokers I'm choosing one ticket out of
those four shows uh December 1st is
still on sale right now but it's going
fast savalan comedy.com hope to see you
guys on the road taste buds they com to
the mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools going to fight but only one food
can be
right folks welcome to t a s t e buds
Halloween episode part
one it's a candy tournament Halloween
candy tournament we're doing four
battles in this one followed up by the
two winners no the four winners of those
battles no two no two winners we have
four battles today eight eight candies
that yields four winners okay so then
that's goes to two brackets that goes to
two brackets and then the the final
battle Yeah so in the next episode we
got the final four okay and then we have
the finals yes the final
two so it's four goes to two goes to one
so it's still three battles in the next
one yes yes yes so this is lots of cover
it's a lot of candy get your candy hats
on I'm almost a little overwhelmed uh we
got to we we all we can do is take a day
by day minute by minute Candy by
candy I I have a lot to talk to you
about but we don't have time we really
don't there's a lot talk about how about
we get these done and if we have any
room on the back end we we we do a
little talking on the back end but can't
make any promises that's fine yeah also
this episode is coming out so far from
when we're recording it yeah there are
already episodes that are dropping that
are going to be the episodes where we
should be covering things like what
happened at skankfest and that sort of
stuff oh correct but those are a little
bit so anyway if you weren't at
skankfest then it doesn't they're not
like well I I needed to know what
happened the day of yeah yeah people
aren't sitting home with a little pad
and a pencil behind their ear yeah uh
anyway folks let's just get to it man
this is this is a heavy episode and I'm
excited I love Halloween I love
Halloween I started my Halloween movie
watching last night oh wow I started
you're well within your right to do that
it's uh it's October I start I start the
beginning of October and I go all month
okay I squeeze it in wherever I can get
it that's what they said so I I did
Insidious 5 The Red Door Insidious 5
Inus part five okay and the red and uh
and talk to me and that's how I started
talk to me I don't know what that is
talk to me was great is it is it like
cat's ey no and you know who loved talk
to me was uh talk to me Ari who hated
cat ey well we all hated cats ey yes but
it was I get it but it was it was did
Nostalgia was enough to make up for the
slow ping talk to me was great okay is
that new yes and is it out in theaters
now it's still barely showing in some
theaters but it it just went to rental
on demand quick overall
premise uh a there there's a party game
where there's a hand like a ceramic
hand and the game is you light a candle
and you hold the hand and you say talk
to me and the spirit of a dead person
appears in front of you okay and if you
say let me in the spirit possesses you
and when they blow the candle out it
jumps out of you but you can only do it
for 90 seconds or else it gets dangerous
and like kids are doing it in this town
in Australia because like they get like
a after the possession they get like a
post Euphoria okay and they like they're
like tick tocking The Possession videos
and everything wow and very very Rel
like of the times yes but it's still
classic horror like it's great it's
great it's really really good you had me
at
[Laughter]
Ceramics Insidious 1 through 4 I I if
you guys see Insidious 1 through
four uh is is it a linear storyline like
five takes off from four is it's just
like one two and three are are line one
two and five are linear Parts three and
four are prequels to part one okay wow
jumps around so real franchise there huh
now is that is that have to do with um
that other one that everyone goes nuts
for uh the of recent times no no it's
like scary there was a few of them uh
maybe Annabelle has something to do with
it oh you're think of The Conjuring yeah
no those aren't World same worlds no but
it's it's it's it's they even as a big
Horan easily confusable because they're
always doing like you know the
conjurings got all those like Branch off
movies and now Insidious is going to
start doing that they just announced a
movie called thread that's like an
Insidious tail and it's part of the
universe but not part of the main story
and Cal Nani's in it so like they're oh
wow Kel's in it yeah yeah wow he's doing
horror that must be fun I would love to
film a horror movie and be in one but
I'll tell you what please yeah but I'll
tell you what I don't like the horror
movies like The Conjuring where it's
like straight just devil demon Doom
Gloom I love that I don't I like a fun
horror movie campy jumpy you know I
think the conjuring is like that though
I when it starts to deal with like deep
evil demons and stuff that's lame to me
lame yeah I I or heavy I don't need to
watch 90 minutes on hellish demons that
are going to come back and that you know
I I like more of like a like a maybe a a
slasher flick or like a you like a
poltergeist you like a nice I'll take a
polter yeah you like a nice haunted
house yeah there's a family Dynamic you
know who's a good actor Will
polter why am I BL oh oh the kid from
uh uh we're we're the Johnson's yeah
Millers We're the Millers yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that was one of his he was
just he's a Ser he's like a dead ass
serious really good dramatic actor what
the hell did I just see oh yeah Gans the
Galaxy the bear have you seen the bear
no babe you haven't seen the bear the
cooking
show well it's not a cooking show yeah
they show about the chefs yeah well it's
but it's a it's a narrative the chefs
have a hot dog place yeah no it's it's a
beef Place uh I mean it's it's it's it's
it's I mean it's A++ I I heard it's
great I want to watch it I'm also a huge
fan of Maddie mat yeah I'm a huge fan of
that guy I love his cooking there he's
pretty cool he's a guy I want to be
friends with Matty mat if you're
watching or listening we know that you
are uh we're big fans uh come on over to
the Pod we like you in our life as a
potentially a real life friend I would
love to have him on this podcast you
kidding me so who knows mty mat I I I
probably bet we know somebody once
removed or something I watched that guy
make pancakes once it was
[Laughter]
nuts take a take us through
it nuts when when he when he mixed the
batter or what was crazy those pancakes
dude I've just never seen pancakes like
this in my life
oh and he he just talks about how much
he loves pancakes and he just makes you
you that do you know that he didn't act
before the bear and he he hits a home
run he's like he's like a com he's like
everyone steals scen this guy yeah I
love this guy man if you know him clip
this and then send it to him and then
look at these what's our email
addressor no press Network gmail.com or
just you know hit us up we'll hit up
your agent or something look at these
come why don't we do a
Hello why I have an idea we get the
wonderful Matty mat on the next live
stream and he does a live cooking
demonstration hey I I think it's a great
idea he has to agree to it no it's
gun I if I know him like I think I know
him he's in
uh birth
control
uh oh okay oh I got it that's funny uh
this is I mean anyway check out Maddie
maton if you haven't if you haven't
before for whatever reason uh he's
excellent he's excellent he's just
reminds me of dudes like I knew like in
like he reminds me like my boys from
back home for sure you know who you know
who we could get on to if he doesn't
want to come we just book him Action
Bronson he'll come cook too you think
Bronson will come through honestly I
like I'm a f Bron too I am too but I
feel like I feel like we know people who
know them I really
do% I know a is a big uh WWE Fan he
probably knows a lot of wrestlers I know
something there's something he lives in
like he lives in like a story we we
probably know like a shopkeeper that
knows
him
shopkeeper he's like he's like within
three degrees of us without question
dude yeah yeah I would love to maybe
we'll we should do you know we should do
a remote one time and we go stake them
out and we'll call it St AK out so it's
like you know what I mean he did an
awesome he did an awesome video where CU
he's been like getting in shape yeah and
he did a video where he like with he
like I guess he trains at like 5:00 a.m.
or something crazy and then he went
outside the gym with his trainer and he
made um what is stuff squid called is
that
baklava well he baka
bakala isn't bakala I think stuff squid
in Italian oh Bobby bakala is bakala
yeah but hea I think it's bakala yeah uh
baklava I think is
theek so he made it in the but he made
it in the parking lot confirm we have
expert he like brought the stuff with
him and made it in the parking lot on
like one of those like Campground like C
grills I like that punk rock running gun
it was awesome it looked so good it was
ah man I love it all right ask me things
that if I can cook things and I'll tell
you yes or no I know the answer is no to
every one of
them uh I mean I've watched you ask
somebody to to prepare you a sandwich
before well that's that's just called
ordering at your bar no no no no not out
of not out of love out of need well if
there was some type of uh if there was
some type of English on the sandwich if
there was a little if there was a little
spin on it maybe I didn't maybe it was
above my pay grade it was if it needed a
certain amount of drizzle or pinch
something or a pinch of something else I
saw you once say tell me what the
sandwich was it was a the you said the
crazy I don't want to say crazy it
sounds all thing it was the wildest
thing I'd ever heard a human being say
that's asking for sandwich okay and I'll
explain and this is coming from a guy
who has a sandwich job yeah and I'll
I'll explain why it was so cra I to see
if you doing me dirty here you said no
no I'm not doing you dirty it was so
crazy to me that you said this you go
shout out to the top guys you were
asking some somebody to make you
sandwich and you said you said you know
what um could could I have you go could
I have ham and American cheese and and
just a little not a lot just a little
turkey for
flavor which I thought was so crazy cuz
turkey has almost no flavor and I was
like I don't understand that's the
craziest thing you've ever heard anyone
say go the other way you'd go you go
just a little of the ham just to add
some flavor to it would you you would
full hir that you went just a little
turkey you're probably right about that
it probably doesn't well was it was it
let me ask you this was it Cracked
Pepper turkey or honey turkey I was
there and I was the one that purchased
the turkey no it was regular turkey it
was just oven gold turkey you know what
you know what happens to me sometimes we
get an I get an array of cold cuts right
and my staple is ham and cheese I like
my ham shredded very thin I like at
least that much on the sandwich and then
about a third a third of that in yellow
American so cuz I really want to feel
the yellow American over white American
we this was one of the pitched first
taste buds battle I wanted to battle
white American versus yellow American I
asked you and then you said it's too it
is it is but I'll do it let's do it put
it in the light around have we done a
cheese tournament holy God bro we have
not done a cheese tournament is this we
have not done a cheese tournament please
write have we ever done any cheese
against each
other that's wild if we haven't done a
cheese tournament no saying we
have we've got some search for cheese
probably wouldn't bring it up no yeah
that's it's not going to bring up
individual cheese cheese tournament we I
probably didn't write like
yeah no but that was dressings oh
provolone versus what go that wasn't you
weren't here for
that I think we get because Emma Wilman
was like saying how much she loves gois
she need it with her fingers hi Emma
Wilman yeah fing she eats almost she
eats almost all her food with her
fingers I've make fun of her about it
all the time interesting with our hands
you mean yeah but like she eats almost
every meal she's just going like this
yeah yeah uh uh so we didn't we do a
proper sliced or proper cheese
tournament for sure age okay so all
right so white and yellow American is
one of the brackets in that um but yeah
so then what I was saying was sometimes
I feel guilty if I also got like turkey
and salami I feel guilty to just have
the ham and cheese I agree so what I'll
do is out throw in one slice of the
other stuff just to like I don't want to
deviate too far from the ham and cheese
what I'm saying is is what a normal
person does is they feel guilty so they
get more of the proper thing and add
less of the guilty
thing full guilty thing and then added a
slice of turkey that healed it up no
just added more calories to the ham you
completely misinterpreted what I'm
saying I feel guilty not to taste have
everything we bought oh so like I I feel
so like throw a slice of this and a
slice of that in it so atast it was the
it was the sentence for
flavor which blew my mind well turkey if
you close your eyes and eat a turkey you
feel you know of course it has a flavor
to it but my point is like when I make I
eat a lot of Just Turkey lunch meat now
because I'm trying to like just eat
overall better so I anytime I have a
sandwich now I'll process sliced cold
cuts in general maybe cuz the sodium you
can get you can get low sodium and all
that stuff you know but like look it's
it's it's it's but anyway I try to stick
with I also get like the Trader Joe's
less sodium whatever this was the move
too this was the
move that's that's another tournament
it's okay this doesn't need to be
Halloween tournament it doesn't how does
it not be Halloween
tournament God damn it
hi what what if we did Halloween
month two weeks for candy coming out on
October 30th we [__] and things around
or no well people do people have that
we're we're not no we're we're switch
stuff out we just lose the story line
yeah but we won't get it because the
next we some for next year yeah no well
we don't have to save that for next year
that this is amazing we've been talking
about doing a candy tournament for years
okay this is amazing I also think sitcom
and I'm wearing the shirt of all
characters oh that's a cool shirt sitcom
characters we watch wrestling podcast
shout outs Matt McCarthy Vince AEL it's
uh sitcom Act sitcom character
tournament is a great one too like yeah
I agree like Ted dancen balky Jack
Tripper all that stuff I agree that's
another huge one all right all right so
keep that keep those in there that's
that's Jason Michael by the way can we
finally do it this year because we've
talked about it again for years November
is right around the corner we we let's
do the Thanksgiving sides tournament oh
yeah I think we did that we've battled
the sides we've never done the
tournament of all the sides I don't
think all right all right we got to get
into this man we we're we're burning the
all right all right pimp let's let's
clock these battles at six minutes
each no six times yes 24 minutes yes
that's perfect that's only 24 minutes
yeah that's great that's right where we
need to be all right six minutes what's
the first one the first one is Milky Way
versus Pena twick all right here we go
uh time to b a t t l e buds boom folks I
want to talk to you about game time a
favorite sponsor here at the tastebuds
podcast I love going to events all kinds
of events uh usually for me it's music
but I also do go see comedy shows
Believe It or Not folks an established
comic like me still pays his way in once
in a while you know what I mean uh and I
will go to the occasional sporting event
even even though I'm not a huge sports
fan theater oh I like theater anyway
here's my point because my schedule is
crazy I don't like to buy tickets way in
advance because because I'm always
afraid something's going to come up and
I won't be able to go to the show I love
game time for this reason game time
helps you get the last minute tickets so
you're not feeling pressure to buy these
things in advance and when you're buying
them last minute with game time they're
letting you know you're getting the best
available ticket for the best available
price they're showing you what it's
going to look like from where you're
sitting you just know everything's going
to be
a uh you know what can I say it's just a
great service for somebody who doesn't
like to commit and boy is that me anyway
last minute tickets Flash Deals Zone
deals uh and they're easy to find and
you know it's the lowest pric again
guaranteed event cancellation protection
job loss protection Etc so check it out
take the guest work out of buying
tickets with Game Time download the game
time app create an account use code
taste buts for $20 off your first
purchase terms apply again create an
account and redeem code taste buds t s
te bu UDS for $20 off download game time
today last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed folks let's talk about prize
picks prize picks the largest daily
fantasy sports DFS platform in North
America the easiest and most exciting
way to play DFS it's just you against
the numbers instead of batt battling
thousands of other players uh including
pros and sharks you pick more than or
less than on two to six player stat
projections and watch the winnings roll
in I like things pimp where you play
against the numbers I don't like
competing against other people I don't
like other people much so I don't want
to compete with them um with basketball
season here you can now pick combo
projections across football and
basketball from the spacious League uh a
league created specifically for combo
projections that includes two or more
players from different sports or leagues
for example LeBron James and Travis
Kel for example LeBron LeBron James and
Travis Kelce at a 2.5 combo of three
points made and receptions uh you want
to play along longside some of prize
pick's favorite players like rapper Meek
Mill and comedian Andrew Schultz
alongside not against
alongside uh you can now find Community
plays under the promos tab of the app to
view entries from some of the biggest
names in the prize pick Community each
week prize pick is a lot of fun uh you
know you all know that I'm not a big
Sports guy but something like prize
picks makes it easy for even somebody
like me to jump in on something like
this and understand it and have a really
really good time with uh with with
playing the fantasy thing so anyway uh
players and stats so anyway go to
prize.com tastebuds and use code taste
buds for a first deposit matchup to
$100 what does that mean it means that
they will match you up to $100 all right
go to prize.com tastebuds and use cod
taste buds for a first deposit match up
to $100 all right Milky Way I'm team
Milky Way you're team peanut butter Twix
I can't believe you have the balls to
come to this table with the peanut
butter Twix I don't understand I'll let
you speak You're I'll say this right now
I love a peanut butter candy you're the
only person on Earth I've ever known to
not just like a peanut butter Twix to
top three top three it's insane third
it's insane to me Milky Way is next the
Snickers is the alltime king candy bar
Milky Way is the way you make a Milky
Way better is you add peanuts and that
becomes a Snickers and that's where the
Snickers is at the top of the mountain
and the Milky Way is like please sir
there's Milky Way is nothing it's boring
it's caramel and chocolate milky way
it's the three Horsemen of a candy bar
dude it's the three Horsemen but you got
you got nougat and caramel and so many
things it's like Milky Way is the first
it's a bit of a dud to me if I have a
Milky Way or Snickers in front of me I'm
going to take the Snickers because it
adds the peanuts and the peanuts has the
crunch Milky Way To Me is a bit of a dud
it's an old fogy candy it's uh the
brother or sister of the Three
Musketeers which I think is one of the
worst candies of all time that's that is
BS it is not the brother or sister of
three mus is all you do is it's the same
exact company and all they did was L
little lir caramel it's the same company
as Snickers
too okay fair and but they so the Three
Musketeers is just nougat and chocolate
then the Milky Way adds the caramel and
then the Snickers adds the peanuts you
just prog and getting better but they're
just trying to make three different bars
out of you hated but here's the thing I
remember when we battled the The Three
Musketeers you you I I believe I was
team musketeer I was no you you yes you
thought you thought Three Musketeers was
good better than the Almond Joy than
Almond Joy I don't know who won that if
you want to let us know but my point is
this I think it was what was
worse yeah yeah your your argument was
the amount of nougat which okay I
understand that
but that does not mean that nougat is
worthless it's like saying it's like
saying oh this candy bar is all
marshmallow fluff so it's disgusting
therefore anything with marshmallow
fluff and it is boring and weak and
whatever no three muskete is twoo much
nougat I get that argument Milky Way
takes the nougat and uses it as a tool
like it should and adds caramel dude
chocolate and caramel together it's it's
game over not better than chocolate and
peanut butter everyone knows that that's
the ultimate combination in life there's
not two things that go to get are better
than chocolate and PE I'll tell you
something Milky Way had a Tay day you
know Milky Way is like Milky Way is like
you know in it was a big dog in like the
70s and back then it was fine but we've
come a long way babe we've evolved candy
you know who else was a big dog in the
70s Black Sabbath still awesome you know
El was a big dog in the 70s Leed
Zeppelin Still rocking I'm failing to
see the connection but you saying the
70s spawned us a lot of big dogs I sure
did but I'm talking specifically about
don't cast the big dogs away you don't
cast aide Black Sabbath who's you know
uh uh uh who's a new shitty I I don't
think I don't think it's a person under
50 that's going into a bodega or a deli
and putting a Milky Way on the counter I
don't believe so that's nuts I don't
believe so it is not when you down in
this 70 candy bar I'll tell you what
it's in nobody's top you know it's a
huge huge huge Halloween candy giveaway
bite-sized milky ways you know what's
not peanut butter Twix I don't know that
I've ever received a but Twix in my
Halloween sure but we're not we're not
limiting it to that right we're doing
chocolates in the spirit of you're
saying you're saying under 50 I'm
telling you under 50 these things are
still sold in the jumbo bags at Target
when you're stack what I said was no
adult under 50 is walking into a Bodo OD
Deli and taking a Milky Way for purchase
and putting it on the counter what you
retorted with what with which I don't
disagree is the only way they're getting
pumped down to the children is in fun
sizes for free because the 50-year-olds
are buying the bag of Milky Way fun
sizes and they're dealing them out to
the kids let me tell you let me tell you
why a Milky Way is better than a Twix
and why or or peanut butter Twix and why
uh caramel and chocolate is a better
combination than peanut butter and
chocolate and I will tell you why nobody
should have just done caramel and
chocolate versus peanut butter and
chocolate you would got your ass handed
to you 99.99 well well that's because
you know because I I get that that
peanut butter and chocolate it from a
flashy standpoint has cornered the
market okay from a marketing standpoint
sure but I'm going to tell you this
right now you know what nobody does
nobody picks through a box box of
Valentine's Day chocolates looking for
the peanut butter and chocolate one
they're looking for the caramel they're
not in there they're looking for you
know why they're not in there cuz
they're low class they have no place to
be they're not in there baby cuz this
cuz of this you because of money you
think that you think that out you think
you think you pick a Stover's or a
Russell Stover's or what's that other
one the any of those chocolate boxes wh
you think that out of the 60 options
they give give you peanut butter is not
in there cuz it's low class they give
you unidentified strawberry creams in
there peach creams it's all bullsh think
a peanut butter cost more than a
strawberry cream are you out of your
mind peanut butter is expensive peanut
butter is expensive please look up a jar
of strawberry cream see if it exists and
I want to do a price compar that's again
you're already off the rails with your
comparison I'm not off the rails look up
black savath and strawberry cream tell
me which one it's it doesn't make any
sense look at me you don't think that
they would choose out of a 50 a 50 piece
assortment box of chocolates they
wouldn't put one peanut butter and
chocolate in there it's the top candy
it's in all of the most popular candies
there is they don't put it in because
they don't have the nothing is romantic
about chocolate and peanut butter s it's
a
children's C be careful what you say CU
this this is going to be an eight bar
bracket and I bet you some of your stuff
has peanut butter in it so be careful
I'm battling I'm battling on a behalf of
a peanut butter candy later on I would
never say I would give it to my lover on
Valentine's Day not what the battle is
about caramel and chocolate is classier
wait you're now we we're talking now
okay so you're battling class not taste
you said you you think that you think
the bar is what what's romantic you said
that chocolate and peanut butter was a
better combo than caramel and peanut
butter I mean and chocolate I said it's
not God would say that from the top of
the mountain chocolate and caramel is
the greatest chocolate combo of all time
let me tell you what I
Joe I see I didn't get I didn't get to
say a word about the twi should have F
better let me say at least one thing
about the twist I look for three things
in my candy bars chocolate peanut butter
and some type of snap or crunch
okay the peanut butter Twix I was a fan
of the regular Twix until the peanut
butter Twix came out and literally blew
two of my balls off and I haven't had my
balls since I tasted a peanut butter
Twix I love them I love everything about
them I think they were better regular
Twix that's what we should have battled
regular Twix versus peanut butter T too
hasty
all right let's go let's go to the vote
no no no no no we'll save it and we'll
go at the end yeah we no no no we don't
we do it through I think we let it let
them get a little bit more like we'll do
the three and then we'll go no no no you
don't think we should let everybody get
some time to vote opposite of what we
did last time but yeah we went through
the phones and stuff last time okay I
think we go to the phones but I'm just
saying like we don't reveal all right so
the end we do all you know what I mean
okay all right let's just do it's going
to be the difference between 2,000 and
10,000 votes the vote let's just go to
the let's go look I choose the candy
that isn't going through an identity
crisis it has a cookie bar in it bro I
don't know a cookie bar hold on but
which do you think he means by
that or she Bailey uh I'd like to get a
Milky Way to reward myself but I'd get a
peanut butter Twix to punish myself get
out of here man yes yes Milky Way is the
only way oh yeah it's a tough one but I
got to go Twix Which object in the Milky
Way is a muddy brown color Uranus I'll
let myself out all right Twix is a mix
of both s and Joe sweet and salty
respectively how can you not want Twix
if you love taste buds I love it yeah
let's pin a classic against a candy bar
that will sit on a shelf for a year then
disappear we don't know what oh I guess
that's I don't know now they're talking
in your favor there I wish this was the
OG Twix but I'll still NAB one over the
Milky Way peanut butter immediately
elevates any chocolate bar that's just
the rule where the hell do you get
peanut butter Twix what do you mean
where the hellal peanut butter in a Twix
Milky Way is boring in the Boomer of top
chocolate bars I said that
baby peanut butter Twix still exists
yeah it does pull your head out of your
ass Kevin wolf listen listen listen to
me no other cookie by the way has a a no
other candy like that I let me know if
you know of it has a cookie bar inside
of it that's a cookie bar in there the
cookie crunch comes you got to stop AR
it comes Crispies and peanuts I get it I
get it that's the only candy with an
actual cookie bar in there we got to
move to the next battle and I get but
that cookie bar is [__] and [__] I also
love how the chocolate and peanut butter
on top of the cookie has like this firm
softness but you break through it and
then you hit the bar you could almost
put a Twix in your mou peanut butter
Twix go like this bite down and pull it
and like have the cookie remain in all
the I love the layering of it it's a
very satis Sal it's it's s conal it's
it's
a peanut butter satisfying by you know
what I don't like about the Milky Way
you know when you bite it there's that
string of caramel that always falls out
you the awesome thing about caramel no
but you pull it it falls out and it hits
you in the chin got pizza the way the
cheese stretches it sucks what are you
talking about I don't understand I don't
understand it you you're not but you're
not agreeing with me that the caramel
falls out and then the caramel strip
lays on your chin and then you got to go
like this and you got and then you SK
you got caramel chin for the rest of the
day the rest of the day all right let's
go to the next battle let's go to the
next battle uh way is a galaxy of
disappointment saw I love that all right
Hershey bar with almonds versus Nestle
Crunch here we go I'm Nestle Crunch no
I'm Hershey bar with almonds you're
Nestle Crunch excuse me okay pimp start
the clock I'll start this time go ahead
please say all you want I think Hershey
bar in and of itself and you throw in
the almonds as an extension might be in
my head the original candy bar I don't
know why I just feel like the Hershey
bar is it is the original candy bar what
do you mean why
I I I couldn't back it up I'm not like
you I don't just throw out absolutes
when I can't back it up Hershey is it's
got to be the original it's got I don't
know I mean maybe it is but so so I
understand the weight that that carries
and I do feel like Hershey doesn't play
like Milky Way to me where it's like
this old kind of you know like this like
Antiquated bar I feel like Hershey kind
of like it just it's kind of like it's
going to be timeless there's nothing you
could do about that now what I will say
is I think you threw in the alas which
which is nice I think you this is going
to be a tough battle I think you might
win this but I respect the Hershey ball
with almonds because it's like a Hershey
bar alone is a little boring it really
is I I never really reach for a Hershey
bar alone the only time I ever get a
Hershey bar alone like milk chocolate
Hershey bar is if one happens to fall on
my lap for one reason or another okay
and by the way what they've done with
the almonds as of late are almond
slivers and chips not whole almonds
which is what they used to do you could
feel the back of that bar and roll your
head over roll your hand over like a
bunch of bumps like the Hershey had some
type of sexually transmitted disease on
it now it's these little little little
cost-saving devices where they put
almond slivers in it okay Nestle Crunch
to me is when I was a kid it was like
one of the best bars there was I love
the rice crisps in it I like the
crunchiness of it uh I just feel like I
enjoy eating a Nestle Crunch more than I
enjoy eating a hershe with almonds okay
if you want to talk Halloween I think
Halloween I think Nestle Crunch is the
ultimate mini Halloween candy even more
so than Snickers I think Nestle Crunch
that two that little two square one that
you break apart uh I was going to say
this before but everybody trades their
milky ways when you do the trades
everyone Trad stop going back to Milky
Way
Focus God damn it all right I just think
that a Nestle Crunch is is better I
think Hershey is a little more subtle
little more plain a little more boring a
little more common I think a Nestle
Crunch has crunch in every single bite
I I like the name a nestly
crunch I like the color pattern it feels
very throwback to me that blue red and
white let me see the clock I like that
no keep going oh I'm talking you can
talk I'm just listening I'm just list
I'm still within my 3 minutes yeah all
right so what's the issue do you want my
retort good retort it's really all I
have to say by the way our favorite bar
which is not in this is a
Whatchamacallit a Whatchamacallit is
peanut butter caramel and it's crisps
okay and crisps are you know I mean you
can't say you hate the crisps cuz
they're in the Nestle they're in the
whatam call I said I hate the crisps
okay but a Nestle Crunch bar is a lot
like you it's just a lot of
air it's just a lot of air okay seems
like there's something there you break
it in half and it's just Hollow little
pockets of hollow
like
you I don't know if that's really
defending the candy but all right I like
how I like how crunch I like how crunch
is written out like that too I love when
I love when there's writing in the
chocolate I will give you this well you
want to talk writing in the chocolate
nobody's topping Hershey let's see it
look at that come on man come on it's
just they are fun little bars it's great
her Hershey comes to the table with
we're gonna give you the full size and
the funsize option out of the same
package first of all second of all I you
could just break any candy apart by stop
it dude it's it's it's sectioned off and
they wrote Hershey in every section
perfectly secondly I can't speak to the
level of almond they're using these days
okay uh but I I I'm going to speak to a
time that I remember the Hershey's
almond bar as being at one point my
favorite of all candy bars at one point
in my life a Hershey's with almonds was
my I couldn't maybe back in the day with
the whole almonds I couldn't get over
how good it was given the Simplicity of
it I'll tell you I couldn't get over
that you know what I like they did a
[__] move Hershey almonds by the way
are an awesome nut when it when they get
elevated the Almond elevated is the
greatest nut on planet Earth give me but
give me a you know what's even better
the Hershey kissan the hershy kiss with
an almond is better than the Hershey bar
with almonds cuz you get one whole
almond on the inside as it was meant to
be Hershey Kiss by the way that you're
exposed right now why am I exposed
because a Hershey Kiss with almond is a
Hershey bar formed into a different
shape but you say you [__] on the kiss
but you love the Hershey you're flawed I
like whole argument is I hate the shape
of the Hershey Kiss I can't stand the
shape crazy I can't stand I can't stand
on peeling that that that stupid you're
crazy that's the thing I think that
Hershey bar bitched out with now it's in
a plastic wrapper give me the foil with
the paper around it like how he grew up
that's what I like I want to open up the
sleeve of paper I want the foil I want
to open the foil I want to fold the foil
back give me the foil I'm sorry I'm
sorry that the world leading Chocolate
Company can't fit their production cost
surround your nostalgic taste no no
that's it can cuz other bars still have
it right there boom boom pow right there
okay give me oh Mars Bar okay anyway oh
my God Zero Bar is there anything worse
than the zero I've never even had it
Zero Bar really everybody that works at
she just get just quit and go drive I'm
going to to quote to quote to quote uh
our friend uh Koo to quote our friend
Koo Hershey with almond bar is all class
100% it is class Nestle's Crunch bar
it's some it's some half-ass Nestle's
chocolate that they took a handful of
Rice Krispies and threw them in and then
pretended like they invented something
Hershey Hershey feels Timeless but
Nestle and n's Crunch childh and
Nestle's crunch is the
Musketeers version of that
Whatchamacallit is the Snickers hold on
let me say this crackle is their version
crackle is the version of Nestle Crunch
makes but let me say this Nestle Crunch
is is the Milky Way or the Snickers to
the Three Musketeers as to they took
nougat and used it as a tool instead of
as a primary focus that's the problem
that Nestle Crunch has they took the
good crunch and they used it as the
primary focus and added nothing else to
it that's
time this guy says manga says
I wipe my ass with almond chocolate bars
just to feel something which is very
funny I thought anything with nuts
usually wins but so far we're not doing
well I don't need to know what date you
are do you think buddy don't give away
the rest I wonder if it's just because
so many people are allergic nowadays uh
never even talk about that I never seen
anyone eating a Nestle Crunch
anymore I'd rather have a Crunch bar
instead of a biting into a Hershey bar
with landmines all over come on guys if
you want a candy bar with some crunch
why would anybody Buy anything other
than the candy bar that literally is
named crunch because it doesn't have
much crunch in it those Rice Krispies
get chewy s you know this is true crispy
V is shaking her head is not V is not
the the the the the president of Nest
crunch opinions she's the people those
Rice Krispies get chewy in there they
don't Crunch at all are you crazy no you
want to talk about we talk about how do
they get chewy Joe how do they get chewy
I don't know maybe sitting in chemical
chocolate on a shelf for six months okay
the candy bar has been around 80 years
it's still called crunch nobody had an
issue with it now it's not called NE
chewy you know nobody had an issue with
the tinf foil wrapper going away except
you my point is is we talk about quality
drop up all the time in here let's not
pretend like the Nestle Crunch is still
coming through Nestle Crunch tastes like
a Hershey dropped
in Nestle Crunch tastes like a Hershey
bar that was dropped in a litter box
here's my issue with Hershey it's
chocolate but for me it's two vanilla oh
God you're talking out of your ass no
I'm talking out of my mouth all right
let's go to the next battle let's go to
the next battle
Butterfinger versus take five ready this
is your wake right now I'm going to I'm
going to lean I'm going to kneel in
front of you and give you condolences I
said to you I'll take Butterfinger cuz I
love a Butterfinger I said to you it's
going to get creamed by the take five
you go your Butterfinger stronger than
you I said take anything you want or
I'll take something
and you said no I love butter finger
let's do it and said it might be it
might why wouldn't it upset it it's did
he not say you you'd be surprised at the
strength of a Butterfinger did he not
say that so do we we agreed on that yeah
so then then don't say it's my wake you
said it had a show because I think take
five is the number two candy of all time
let me tell you what sucks about to take
five that means anything below it let
tell let me tell you what sucks about a
take five it is a showof candy bar it is
trying to do you told me you never had
it and you don't know what's in it I'm
telling you what's so how's it a showoff
tell I'm can I say name the ingredients
in it don't pimp take it away pretzel
chocolate cookie and nougat
caramel there's more there's five yeah
you get it Joe pretzel chocolate oh
crisps uh what is it four chocolate is
four what's the fifth one oh marshmallow
no it's not there's not marshmallow in
it marshmallow cream right there no it's
chocolate pretzel crisps caramel and
peanut butter that's what's in it it's
everything it's the PowerHouse okay and
by the way a chocolate covered pretzel
is literally gives me life as my niece
says Okay a chocolate covered pretzel I
think is probably the most perfect candy
there is and and it's the only candy bar
to throw the pretzel in it's the only
one oh no no no now you got M&M's trying
to trying to throw little pretzel balls
in there and but as much as I love the
Eminem and brand those memem pretzel
ones you got to have another meeting and
you got to come up with something else
tell why let me tell you why Reese's
fails with the take five okay oh it's so
good dude it's show it's a show off
candy bar Reese just acquired the take
five it wasn't always Reese it's a
showof candy bar too much trying to do
trying to do way too much secondly just
what does that mean what does that mean
a show off candy bar it's trying what do
you mean what not trying to do too much
it's accomplishing what it needs to I
can tell you what sucks about it okay
every one of those ingredients when you
you bite into it is mushy none of it
retains a crisp none of it retains a
freshness you get a chocolate cover
pretzel at a candy shop that where they
make them or whatever you bite into it
you're like that's a goddamn pretzel
covered in chocolate you get a you get
one of these mass-produced candy bars
with a pretzel in it it's mushy it's
chewy you're wrong you you haven't even
had it I had it once in the car with you
and Q when I was on tour with you guys
and that's my Take
Five
well it's appropo that you took
Butterfingers cuz you just Bobble
everything that you touch no yeah your
arguments are all over the whole
different story you're comparing nou to
to to to to Rozi Osborne I don't know
what you're talking about okay the the
take five takes the five best elements
in candy okay F nougat F the other stuff
a f the Wafers it takes the five best
maybe a wafer but and it puts them
together and every every one of them is
the perfect amount and there's a Synergy
there and no one ever did it before take
five it Bulls my mind that no one ever
did it and I honestly when that came
when that came out it was the first
candy bar since the Whatchamacallit that
stopped me right in my
flipflops let me tell you look in my
opinion take five is up there with take
five is up there with Oreo Pizza it's up
there with you know Oreo Pizza it's too
much it's what the what's an Oreo Pizza
you remember when Domino's or whoever
had Oreo Pizza they put Oreos on the
pizza it was a dessert pizza it was
disgusting my point is is I bet it
wasn't but I get it but there's a such
thing there's a such thing as too much
the take five is capitalism at its worst
look how big it is it's the fifth
Avengers movie look we're shoving it all
in are we getting is it enough is it
enough more people more more more money
money money money more ingredients it's
too much we
get that weak ass argument out of here
it's not a weak ass argument money money
money talk about the taste bro The Taste
is amazing it's amazing to take five
there's only one bar better than it for
me that's
it disagree I disagree I think that um I
think that uh it's too many God my hand
just went numb is that
bad God what if I had a heart attack
right now well I mean then this is
sweeps week we put this we save this
holy [__] you okay you sure you weren't
leaning on the elbow on the chair in a
way that would cut circulation at
someone now I'm fre fre the Apple watch
is making my hand go numb no that's
that's that's crazy is it actually what
time is
it what where are we at time wise in
this battle uh 450 450 220 there
supposed to be some kind of cancer
evk all right I thought it was just an
alarm but why why is it a cancer event
let's talk let's talk about later all
right why 2K so for closing argument you
can't just drop your conspiracy theories
on me in the middle of a chocolate
argument and then wave it off tell me
there's going to be a a doomsday cancer
Y2K event and then when I go really you
go no just talk about the it's
not it's not it's a very simple thing
it's not a doomsday thing uh anyway
let's let's closing AR let's about the
Butterfinger yes yeah the Butterfinger
you chew if you chew a Butterfinger you
bet first of all you your teeth all
better be real you can't have implants
you can't have Dentures nothing like
that second of all you better want to
taste that Butterfinger for at least 24
hours because you ain't getting it out
of the cracks and crevices you have a
better easier time eating a three corn
on the cobs and getting stuff out of
your teeth the Butterfinger feels like
you're eating something that is you're
eating like papier-mâché loaded with
like I don't know what on it okay
Butterfinger does what your candy bar
fails to do it and so does your peanut
precious peanut butter Twix fails to do
it the the Butterfinger takes peanut
butter and it morphs it into some other
substance unidentified I will agree to
that I will agree that there is a
science behind the Butterfinger that I
do not understand I don't I don't
understand it either because they know
that there is no way that peanut butter
or peanut or peanut cookie or whatever
the hell you want to call it is going to
work inside of a chocolate bar that sits
on the Shelf so they take it they
chemically alter it and they give you
what you want [__] dude flaky
crispiness that's wonderful flaky
crispiness my ass right it feels like
you're biting into a stale sheetrock
that's what it feels like I don't I
don't know what that texture is do you
what's in there what are all those what
are all those really really gooey sticky
flakes in there peanut
flakes nobody knows isn't that kind of
what does it say what does it say it is
on the package or it says something on
the
package how do how does how does
Butterfinger describe
itself just on the package on the pack
click on click on the picture right
there yeah yeah it should say right
underneath it right it should say kind
of what it what it is on
there like no on the bar
itself on the bar
yeah yeah like give me
that pimp the the just zoom in on the
picture Crispy Crunchy peanut buttery
bar they're elusive they're an
exclamation point after buttery it just
ends at peanut
buttery look oh yeah Crispy Crunchy
peanut buttery yeah that's sus to me bro
that's very sus look at it dude look at
it you break it open and you know what
it looks like it looks like the side of
like the Grand Canyon you know like it
looks like the side of like an eroded
Earth it looks like
strudel strudel and the grand canion is
what it looks like and you know they
they're very elusive on the description
go to the they call the bar goodness
yeah I know because they don't want they
don't want to let you know what me that
they that they [__] I don't know what
they I think it's stale flak it's
awesome I think it's stale flakes mixed
with a little bit of uh eroded uh Grand
Canyon I think it's awesome all right
let's oh it is the elbow I just caught
myself doing it okay all right go to the
phones take five is literally the best
candy bar ever made yeah that's a big
surprise while the Butterfinger is like
a Frankenstein candy bar made up of
leftover ingredients here here
Butterfinger all the way until they
change the formula now it tastes gross
do you remember Butterfinger BB's those
were the
best uh Butterfinger can take the
longest walk off the shortest pier there
you go take five is fighting a noble but
probably doomed fight to a lousy
chocolate covered tree bark of a candy
wow tree bark very nice take that's it
your goodness your buttery goodness is
tree bark that's what it is take five or
the volon you know what fat Jesus fat
Jesus I wish I could have come up and
articulated it this way take five is the
Voltron candy bar except instead of
defending the Galaxy it gives my mouth
an org an orgasm take five doesn't need
it's volon B it's it's five right it's
the blue the black the green the yellow
and the red coming together take five I
don't to save humanity take five doesn't
need to advertise leaving me alone and
getting your own because no one is
picking it I don't what does that
mean okay take five could take a bath it
can't lay a finger on my
butter the greatest slogan in candy
history outside of the Sni what was the
Snickers one really
satisfies Snickers really satisfied
Snickers just had a couple now where
it's like Snickers will make you not
hung over no better lay a finger on my
butter finger nobody better lay a finger
on my butter finger tell you nothing I
don't love a body part in the name
you know I don't want to be eating a
finger a butter finger think about that
actually the image that that conjures up
is pretty disgusting it feels like Emma
Wilman just sucking on a butter finger
sexy I think it's Central you know she
you said she eats with only a fingers we
got to go to the last battle here we got
to go to the last battle here final
battle I just picture a finger and
butter and that's not what I want to all
right here we go rollos versus junior
miss also take five you know why I love
the name how we got to do the batt it's
a perfect Breakaway
I just don't understand why you ignore
the rules completely Rolo versus junior
Mintz tell the people who you took in
this B I took the one that's going to
really really win are you nuts Junior
Mintz you think Junior Mintz is going to
take Rolos I'm so confident I'll place a
side wager on it what's a side wager
what do you mean it's anything we want
it to be what that's what I'm saying
what's the side wager I thought you said
what's a side wager what's the I might
have phrased it like that but I didn't
mean to what's the side wager so that's
on you then it might be what's the side
wager um let's think of it cuz I'm very
confident that Junior mint if not at all
that is the most depart departure from
any of the ones we're battling it's okay
it's always a refreshing treat I like
that it still comes in that cardboard
box you got the Seinfeld push from it
Rolo is like if
you if you have a slightly bad memory
you don't even remember a Rolo R isn't
even invited to the part
R was big in like
1984 but that's it and by the way it's
just peanut butter and caramel again
Rollo is so Rolo is everything you want
in the Russell Stover chocolate box in
one roll they're like hey guys don't go
get H don't get Valentine's candy you're
too young to have a lover we got you
covered man come get some rollos I love
their that they're ass to back they're
ass to ass in the package that they
don't all face the same direction they
don't I believe they go what are you
crazy no no I think they go the top to
top and then back to back and then top
to top and then back to back I don't
know about that bro I think they're
stacked can you can you
howo oh and they used to have the
individual gold wrapping on them you
just [__] on Hershey Kiss just back off
bro yeah no you know why I [__] on
Hershey Kiss silver gold Rolo coming out
Hershey Kiss with almond are gold gold
rollos are awesome man there it is there
it is there's a guy unpacking them yeah
so here's the thing I don't even know do
they you can buy a Rollo at a local
grocer or is a Rollo just like a what do
you mean I a they it's a roll of candy
roll I know what it is I'm asking you do
they still sell it everywhere see how
they're see how they're like okay that
one was that way let's see the next one
yeah see now now that one's ass is that
way now watch the next one the head will
be in in in the front look at look at
the okay oh no I guess not I thought
that this is a wonderful candy dude
you're getting bite-sized you're getting
bite-sized chocolate caramel pops boom
boom boom let me tell you about a junior
man Junior man after two you're like
okay well my breath is somehow fresh and
foul now cuz I've had chocolate and milk
the chocolate is making my breath too
sweet which gives you bad breath and the
mint has refreshed it and I don't know
my mouth is you can't eat a whole Jun
outside of pepm Patty is the only candy
bar that will give you refreshing breath
and I'll tell you what happens for real
I'll tell you what happens for real
after two I'll tell you what happens for
real after two you cannot not take a
third Junior Mints once you get a taste
Babe oh Babe once you get a taste for a
junior mint you have to go back and you
know what Junior mint by the is the most
wonderful put it in your mouth and let
it melt you don't even need teeth the
best way to have a junior Min is you put
it in there and you let nature take it
course you got the balls to come to the
table with some of my candy choices are
for 50-year-olds only and you're
defending Junior Mints has there ever
been a candy found more frequently next
to crumpled tissues in a purse than
Junior Mints Ros this is Nana candy dude
this is Nana candy Butterfinger rollos
like dude this is this is a step above
getting a free don't have the bowl that
sits at the cat Reg Diner not even close
bro not even and by the way Seinfeld it
wasn't a Seinfeld episode and you know
what Jerry says Kramer I don't want it
he doesn't want it because Junior Mints
are just it's a weird acquired taste you
want once in a while it's not it's very
it's very resistible it's very
resistible somebody says you not not
once you have one I can dude I can
resist the Rolo if it was Halloween in
the desert whatever that means you
understand what I'm saying alond candy
is a waste of calories that's not true
and I'll tell you another thing this is
another thing this is why also Joe
there's literally a Rolo
McFlurry boom boom boom make it say
way you all right you got your
McDonald's out here's the thing because
there's no other candy aside from pepp
and Patty like the juniorman I don't
think I I think that that's why it's
still so relevant there's no competition
they did it it's done they combin it
there's after dinner mins there's any uh
Peppermint
Patties you're not listening to me when
I talk you just don't listen when I talk
sometimes I don't a lot of times lately
a lot of times lately I said aside from
The Peppermint Patty there's not one
other yeah but think about how many
things have peanuts peanut butter
caramel CH 25 things each this is a
stand it's an island of its own baby
it's a you know what else doesn't have
any competition Necco Wafers you know
why they suck they suck you're you're
you're you're defending a candy that's
in a [__]
uh uh uh uh uh minority box here like
it's it's not it's just nobody wants to
make peint the peppermint is just so
original that what are you going to do
you're going to copy it again it already
exists in two forms that are excellent
about you want to talk about by
Peppermint Patty a good there's also
nothing you can mix with a PE with
peppermint it's chocolate peppermint
that's it you're out the door it's all
it needs dude it's all it needs and and
and the breath stays fresh it's the only
candy you could have that does that with
chocolate in it and they're addictive
after one they're great to melt in your
mouth I love that they come in the Box
rollos honestly I truly honestly I've
never purchased a Rolo I've had them
I've never purchased one he just ignores
the clock I've never seen someone
purchase one I haven't seen a commercial
for one I haven't heard people talk
about one do matter none of this matters
clock means end of argument it doesn't
mean you go for as long as you feel like
I think today a lot of your arguments
are very doesn't matter we reached time
that is the end all right mints have no
business in the world of chocolate says
who Junior Mints don't belong in a
battle of this caliber you're crazy if
Rolo wins this I'm telling you I'll make
a side wager I believe in the go what is
the side I know what do you want to do
it's your idea you tell me put your
money where your mouth is okay or my
money I got Rollo wins I buy you like a
store like a case of rollos I can't eat
them anymore cuz I got my chocolate
allergy
now I don't I give up I give up give me
money how about that money all right
what do you want to bet 20 30 40 you you
call it a hundro a hundo you call it you
call it it's your idea I want to see how
confident you feel right now I bet 100
if you want 100 you would to bet $100
you son of a [__] bet either pick it or
whatever I'm asking I'll bet 20 I'll bet
30 I'll bet what I'll bet whatever you
want it's called a cool 50 cool 50 all
right okay and I like it because it's
cool like the junior mint all right here
we go pimp just take us right to the
votes let's go to the end here and is
this
payable do that last is this payable
upon Pawn receipt here yeah you got 50
on we'll venmo we'll we'll venmo one
another yes okay here we go pimp ready
we starting with peanut butter Twix and
Milky
Way I think that people like the Twix a
lot more so I this might be tough but I
really do think Milky Way is old all
right pimpy
pimp here we go baby here we go pimp
Pimp's going to the pimp does pick the
peanut butter Twix as he should and
Milky Way takes it Milky Way takes it
Milky Way takes it hot now 5,000 votes
you got Milky Way winning
52.9% to 47.1 that's a very close battle
I am surprised I am surprised I think
Milky Way had a bigger history and is
just a bigger name but when I honestly
if you put it to The Taste it's peanut
but Ts for me we got 3,700 votes Hershey
bar with almond versus Nestle Crunch
somebody already hinted that Hershey bar
lost but let's see where we're
at and and I can't believe the stats on
this one okay the Nestle Crunch I mean
Wallops the original Hershey bar with
almonds very surprised 67% even to 33%
that's just a tad above double I didn't
think that uh I didn't think that that
the was still popular I'm surprised I'm
surprised this is this is more
surprising this is surprising yeah I
thought I was going to lose I really did
not not win by double that's crazy oh
the Nestle Crunch is uh I mean we know
where this one's going now how do we
know
how do we know how well you don't have
confidence in why did you choose it I
told you before we did it Butterfinger
will get cream by take five you said I
think you'll be surprised at how strong
the Butterfinger does we both said that
and I think you will be but here's the
thing you think take five sucks and you
love Butterfinger so why and you said
you don't even taste a take five so then
why would you be like here we go I'm
going to get vote in this country is to
be indulgent people also thought The
Avengers movies were great stop making
dumb comparisons it's not comparisons I
am not a man of the Common Man I am a
man of the well palleted man you
understand the the tree bar the the
unidentified Butterfinger is well
palleted all right Pimp's going
Butterfinger by the way which I can't
believe what
what how could you act like that when
you
just I can't believe it I know but you
don't want to you don't want to accept
the idiocy of what you just said finger
C
Cut You Down I thought take five was
going to win the tournament I thought
take five was going to win the
tournament perent Butterfinger take
64.4% to takes 5 35.5 that's the upset
for me of the entire tournament right
now I got to tell you it upsets me
almost I want to see where Butterfinger
goes cuz if Butterfinger makes it to the
finals on something that you had no
confidence in and then just double back
and said you made me take Butterfinger
when I knew t five would win cuz
capitalism The Avengers Andor I didn't
say you made me take it I said I didn't
think it was going to win that's what I
said you Joe Joe Joe you know what I
want to do you know what I want to do I
want to do a special episode I want to
do an episode where we sit here and it's
like a mystery science Thea 3000 and I
want you to watch all the things that
you say and then contradict one sentence
later okay okay yeah we get I mean
you're this is rough bro I got oh I'm
I'm taking this I'm taking this this is
50 this's 50 bucks on the 50 Grant what
do you mean oh who's on the dollar bill
I mean the $50 bill I have no idea catch
up I can't tell you the last time I've
seen a $50
bill I'm serious you could have see one
in the second hundreds 20s I don't see
see one in the second 50 is my favorite
Bill Grant it's Grant it's Grant and
look we got 4,300 votes in the last few
minutes pimpy's going Junior Min I just
want to say you you were very confident
and I'll be surprised if J I'll be very
surprised if Jun Min loses but you very
confident I I didn't I wasn't you know
puffing my chest on any of these really
except take five but I think Jun wins
click I told you your [__] dentist
office candy wasn't going to take this
you might as well argue toothpaste
versus the Rolo oh my God guys where
were you are you kidding me guys I got
to give him $50 eight do it on air I
want to see it happen on
air bet dude we should we should have
bet what the what the winning percentage
was that would have been fun 68 6% I am
in I am in I am literally reeling in
shock from two these two upsets I can't
believe that you that Rollo won 68.3 I
thought nobody would even know what a
Rollo was do you know what a Rolo is did
you know what a Rollo was so you tell me
if they don't even know what it is how
did you win by more than double
everybody do you know what a junior mint
is because your candy is so bad that
people voted against it to to a degree
but they voted for a candy that has not
been seen in public since 1986 I'm
shocked man I am shocked and now I got
to figure out what I got to take down
the tournament because again one of mine
lost oh yeah one of yours lost three of
yours lost only one of mine won oh
that's that's that's this is a this is
tough I'm going to go ahead and just I'm
going to go ahead and pull up the venmo
for you right now I don't have I don't
have venmo I have PayPal or I I can okay
then just PayPal write to me baby you
want me to do it now oh yes I do it's
waste inv valuable time where we at
doesn't matter we're way over but but
fooya is waiting out there but he's
going to wait until I receive these
funds uh all right how does it feele how
does it feel how does this feel vict
this feels I'm going to when I put the
received $50 email in the in into the
camera this feels better this this might
be the best I felt on this show Almost
ever this was just beautiful today
smarts did you send it I'm I'm getting
there babe can't find the right cont I I
have it send I have you in here look
what am I doing wrong Joe
D oh sorry I got it come on PayPal let
me know already we we got to show sense
there it
is
right
here okay there you go s Vol s you $50
information that on there right if pimp
make sure no information goes out but I
don't think so look no there's a
transaction ID and then it just says
that's not good it says hello Joseph to
Roa
okay man ptim can you cut out the
transaction ID
sure this is this is I still love you
buddy I love you
too
t f they like two fools going to fight
but only one food can be right taste
buds man yeah they coming to the